one guy who probably will not be
reacting very favorably if there is a
suspension of Ezekiel Elliott his
cowboys owner Jerry Jones because we
know two years ago he did not react well
when Ezekiel Elliott was suspended but
now Jones and Roger Goodell are on the
same page as to one very significant
current NFL project and that is the
collective bargaining agreement we
reported yesterday at pft that Jerry
Jones has taken a very prominent role in
the negotiations that have occurred so
far between the NFL and the NFL Players
Association there have been three such
negotiating sessions there are more to
come in July but Jerry Jones has been a
key player on behalf of ownership and
and the thinking is that because Robert
Kraft the owner of the Patriots got so
much credit for getting the last CBA
done this is Jerry Jones opportunity to
kind of pick up some of that same rava
toss he's already in the Hall of Fame
right this is about legacies at this
point this is about how people view
Jerry Jones and this may be at a certain
level about getting everyone to forget
about what happened a couple of years
ago with that very clumsy awkward effort
to take down the commissioner with an
assist from Papa John so now Jones a
significant amount of influence in these
discussions is that good is that bad
time will tell we've previously reported
the league would like to have a new CBA
in place by the start of the regular
season I'd be shocked if that happens I
think Superbowl week is the is the most
realistic best-case scenario even then I
don't think that I would wager that it's
going to happen but it's gonna happen at
any point between now and March it's
gonna happen I would say Super Bowl week
and I think there's a chance that the
two major planes that Roger Goodell is
trying to land they could land
simultaneously are close to it new CBA
new TV deals and the Commissioner could
hold that up like Simba prior to the
Super Bowl
I guess one in each hand and they could
ride off into the sunset and there's a
thought that that's where this is
heading new CBA new TV deal Roger
Goodell walks away maybe that's why he
reaches is taking such an active role
this is a way that two years after the
fact he can get what he wanted in 2017
which is a new commissioner
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports